pas facile de respecter le deux mètres
de distance et c'est presque impossible
de savoir si vous avez croisé un inconnu
contagieux pour vous aider il y aura
bientôt une application l'australie
donne un avant goût de ce qui attend les
canadiens chaque jour le premier
ministre vente l'application mobile
coville
c'est essentiel dit il pour se protéger
tout en redémarrant l'économie mais
après un mois d'utilisation
le résultat n'est pas au rendez vous
c'était populaire au début raconte ce
canadien qui vit là-bas mais maintenant
l'engouement a ralenti moins de 20% des
australiens l'ont téléchargée c'est
nettement insuffisant pour retracer les
chaînes de contamination selon cet
expert
ça nécessite effectivement ce genre
d'applications 1 1
un taux d'adhésion très très grand à
dire quand il parle de 60 70 % d'une
population qui devrait l'utiliser
voici comment une telle application
pourrait fonctionner au canada votre
téléphone utilise la technologie blue
tout pour échanger des données et garder
une liste anonyme de gens avec qui vous
entrez en contact
si une personne est déclarée positive à
la colite 19 la santé publique sera mise
au courant et pourra contacter
rapidement les personnes possiblement
infectés
c'est le risque le risque de faux
positifs c'est à dire qu'on risque ni
d'alerté beaucoup de gens pour rien
ottawa laisse entendre que l'application
canadienne ne sera pas obligatoire mais
la pression sera forte
c'est quoi le niveau de liberté complète
qu'on va avoir à utiliser ça si jamais
on met dans la balance c'est le moyen de
sauver des vies et puis de retrouver une
vie normale
michael mon honneur il est encore à
utiliser l'application australienne si
ça sauve une vie où c'est yvette une
éclosion super style peut-être que ça en
vaut la peine
président m auxquels les canadiens
seront bientôt confrontés malgré une
application à l'efficacité limitée
choisiront-ils de protéger leur famille
pour leur vie privée
c'est christian noël radio canada à
ottawa